foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to learning with jagman
X today I continue with taking you
behind the scenes while I create my next
music video in annual engine by showing
you some pretty embarrassing prototypes
and drawings that prove that if I can do
it so can you since the last update I've
had my hair cut to look like an icon
it's a little bit long still though so I
probably have to cut it again but also I
have made some progress on the music
video
last episode I was explaining how I
wanted to recreate a character
reminiscent of what forbidden siren did
with their characters how they took
photographs of the actors and had it
like projected onto their faces so
concept artist Braden May created us a
low poly character model to use which
was based upon the reference of metal
gear solids character typology once we
had this we then took photographs of two
different facial expressions so nothing
fancy we literally just took the photos
on my white wall and then Brayden used
these pictures to create a texture
using the UV unwrapping of the head from
that low poly 3D model he had already
created what's really important about
prototyping very quickly is that you
learn what you did wrong and what you
need to do next time so we've learned
that taking pictures of my face wax but
my hair a little bit crazy we should
just model that and put it on top of the
head so we're going to just scrape my
hair back when we take the next photos
and also we need to have the lighting be
consistent so we need to make sure there
are no Shadows on my face at all so I
can have complete control over the
lighting in Unreal Engine itself also
Braden has realized that um mirroring
the face although it seemed like a
really good way to save some time wasn't
actually the best way to create the
textures because it doesn't look like my
face no one's face is perfectly mirrored
I remember there was like a tick tock
Trend I think where people were
mirroring their faces and most people
just looked very strange I look strange
if my face is mirrored so we're not
going to do that when we create the
proper facial expressions but for now it
works pretty well so when the modeling
and texturing part was done I could then
use the low poly character model and
create a rig for it by actually just
plopping it into miximo because miximo
will create its own rig and I also
exported some standard animations for
miximo as well just to test out
animating this character then once I had
downloaded the animations and skeleton
from miximo I could use the same
skeleton for each animation that I had
downloaded in Unreal Engine all I had to
do was replace the model and the
animations that I was already using in
my prototype from last video with the
new assets that I had so to create the
facial expressions I needed to create a
Sprite sheet of these that could be used
for the flipbook in Unreal Engine so it
will automatically flip through all the
facial expressions even though I'm only
using two at the moment so I put them
into Photoshop and I used this image to
spray right I think it's called
Script that you can download and then
use in Photoshop and once I have my
spreadsheet I can then put that into
animal engine and use that in my
material that I'd already set up with a
flip book that just flips through all of
the Sprites from the first one to the
last one however I realized I wasn't
getting the small Crossfade that I
noticed when looking at forbidden Sirens
characters you see in between all of
their facial expression changes there
was a moment where the images would
slightly Crossfade over one another and
because mine was just using a flip book
it was just flipping from one to the
next to the next without actually fading
over all of the different Sprites I was
actually really surprised to see that
the flip up node didn't have any options
for this and if you know of any inherent
options for crossfading between Sprites
in a flip book in Unreal Engine do let
me know in the comments but what I did
in the end was actually just set up two
flip books of the same Sprite sheet and
have the output material just outputs a
blend of both of these flip books and
then just have one start slightly
earlier than the other this way there
would be a Crossfade of
0.03 seconds I think I made it in the
end a very very small amount of time
when they were out of sync and it would
look like they were crossfading around
one another feels like a cheat but it
works and I kind of like it so that's
what I'll keep I guess now of course
you're probably seeing it on screen and
it looks super Derpy right now
um but I promise you it's gonna look so
much better with more Expressions I can
see it in my head and I'm pretty happy
with the way that it turned out I've
also created a storyboard
very rough I usually would not share
something like this my creative process
whenever I do something like creative
storyboard or come up with the initial
idea of what I think something should
look like and what the meaning of it
should be in all of this wishy-washy
creativy stuff is just to sit on the
floor surround myself with notebooks
pens pencils my laptop and just submerge
myself in whatever I want the creation
to entail so whether that's imagery
video I watch documentaries or
commentaries on things that I find
inspiring for the piece that I'm making
at the time and then I have a nap
honestly this has always worked for me
especially if I come to a roadblock and
I don't exactly know where I'm gonna go
next I think going to sleep for me
shuts off my anxieties it also shuts off
anything that can distract me and being
in that zone in between awake and deep
sleep allows me to formulate ideas that
I can't do when I'm fully awake I don't
know how to explain it but nap time is
great time and if you're ever stuck in a
rut and you don't exactly know what to
do with a great project you're working
on maybe just try that method I just
Googled this but it was used by Thomas
Edison Salvador Dali and Albert Einstein
to get their creative juices flowing and
to come up with creative ideas around
solutions that they couldn't come up
with in their Waking Life so try the nap
method it works I think one of them I
don't know who but they would sleep with
um heavy objects in their hands so
before they reached a deep sleep they
would wake up because they would drop
the heavy object and then start writing
down whatever they're thinking of I've
just trained myself to wake up after 20
minutes by setting an alarm and that
took maybe about a year but the heavy
object might work I don't just don't
hurt anyone and don't hurt your toes but
yeah so you ready to see the storyboard
oh it's gonna be so good
yeah it's not that good my terrible
drawings are for me and meant for only
me it's kind of just my Rambles about
what environments I need what kind of
shots I'm thinking about and what's the
overall narrative language is that I'm
going for when I talk about narrative
language I'm talking is it first person
is it third person if I'm using third
person shots am I ever using kind of POV
shots from something else that could
signify the monster because I'm doing a
spooky horror music video as well as the
ambience the environments what's going
to be happening and what I need from my
concept artist to actually create these
environments in our real engine there is
kind of a time frame of where I think
the shots should be placed within the
song itself however it's very rough it's
not final and I try not to spend too
much time on this because I know it's
going to change but yeah usually I would
not be sharing anything like this but I
guess this is what this whole series is
for right it's showing you everything
from start to finish and that includes
the really embarrassing things so you're
welcome and from this I was then able to
add all of the locations that I want all
of the props that I want onto the Google
Doc that I share with you last episode
so it's more fleshed out now and I can
share that with Braden and we can talk
about which props Brayden would like to
create and which props I can look online
to buy for the environments I want to
use a block of flats that has an Atrium
in it and also has a bunch of corridors
with various flat doors and I'd also
like a winding staircase I feel like a
poodle whenever I get my hair cut it's
crazy the next steps are now for Braden
to start creating the environment what
he'll do is he'll create it in little
parts so that I can then have elements
of it to create as if I were a level
designer so for instance instead of
doing the whole Corridor or something
he'll just make one wall that then I can
use whenever I want so I can figure out
the layout of the corridors that I want
and I'll make one door one window you
get what I'm saying here and then I can
just play with it all in the environment
and create a blockout because that's
another Next Step that I wanted to do I
wanted to block out all the environments
in Unreal Engine and then this will help
me to position my cameras I can follow
my storyboard that I have already
written out but I can also create kind
of another storyboard but within Unreal
Engine itself so I can actually see what
it looks like in the cameras and by
blocking it out even if we don't have
the final assets yet especially with the
final character because we're going to
have to start from scratch with the
character again we can use the model
maybe just change it a little bit but
especially with the the faces we're
going to have to start from scratch
taking images of those we can just add
that in later when I have all of my
characters and my environments blocked
out I also know what I want the ambience
and the weather to be like in the music
video and that is stormy I want there to
be rain I want there to be lightning
thunder so I actually need to figure out
how to do that in a retro style as well
because I don't have that as part of my
retrographics pack so that'll be quite
interesting and I'll I'll need to look
into that okay so there you go that is
my next steps that I have to go I always
feel like I haven't done enough
um but it's time for me to make another
update so hopefully that was enough to
be somewhat interesting for you these
things take time and there's always more
things to do that I did not realize I
had to do at the beginning so this will
be interesting we'll see how we get on
but I think at the moment I am where I
expected to be I finished my storyboard
I know what I want to do in Unreal
Engine I figured out how to do the
technical Parts apart from rain because
now I need to figure out how to do rain
but I'm sure that will be fine and if
you want to learn how to create music
videos short films or of course games in
Emerald engine my friends over at
gamedev.tv have courses for you to learn
just that so check them out in the link
down below and it will be an affiliate
link so you can help out me and my
channel as well and a massive thank you
to my patreons who make this all a
reality I know I've been trying to give
you a bit more behind the scenes lately
so I hope you've been enjoying that
because I am really really grateful to
every single one of you and if you want
to support the channel the patreon link
will also be in the description down
below where you can get access to early
videos as well as more more behind the
scenes contents and uh some music as
well if you want to see more of that
don't forget if you want to see more of
me as well you can catch me on
twitch.tv yagman X I'm usually streaming
every week or so I am getting so
distracted by my Fringe I need to go I
probably need to cut it myself thank you
so much for putting up with me in my
gigantic Fringe this evening morning
afternoon whatever time it is for you
and have a lovely day or evening good
[Music]
do